the expectation the hopes for this or
how Ridley Scott's involved Harrison you
were involved but presumably this isn't
the first time I'm just involved okay my
question is it so it must have been
mentions of a sequel between it was 1982
wasn't it when it came out so between
then and now so what why now why not
before I guess cuz Ryan wasn't available
yes
well not for thirty years but they were
waiting for me to grow up what they
decided to have to go ahead anyway yeah
I came up with a good with the story I
read it and I thought it was awesome I
thought it was great and I as I read it
I read about the character that Ryan
play and I said and I with great
enthusiasm I called up the producers and
I said this is great I can't wait to get
Rob uh and not a great park why don't we
see if we can get Ryan
and they said Oh Brian guy said why not
this is a great part for Ryan Gosling
and they said we've been talking to him
for months now wait a second they'd only
been talking to me for weeks
didn't know who she was playing in the
film it was in the cinema before you
came on a chat show why this they also
cuz contractually no offence but it was
sort of asked to come and
[Applause]
doesn't wanna be here there
great I do wonder why they asked me to
do it she's never been one of my father
she's good
[Music]
how long you got man it's just like I
before it is the wards governor
governor's wards and she was really cool
when we just spoke about stuff it was
really nice I didn't know he was English
cuz these acts I was so flawless and get
out and I was like oh my god and anytime
I meet anyone who's English I'm just
immediately like I love London I miss
the two of them I met I met weapons yeah
I met Denzel then so on Oprah at the
same time it was what it was this this
segue it was just this leg I don't know
black african-american excellent segue
or I don't know came up to me was that
you came talking English accent that
yeah mate yeah cheers mate cheers mate
cheers me and I'm like what what's
happening how do you know anyways like
and anyways he's worth like um the Opera
in the open let's meet Oh
and I just yeah I'm a hugger so good in
grammar I swear is just premium but when
I do I'm gonna hug her for free that's
the Golden Globes but she was too far
away you go I inhale deeply she was
really cool
now I hate to pick on Eddie any you're
kind of will we were saying a sexual
awakening was was was a two-dimensional
sexual awakening oh no it's true I was
wanted to be a nurse like you know who
would that your first crushes and and
and I did I loved the lion king when I
was younger and I had a with Nala
[Applause]
look at her face she's so sweet
you can sing really well that's wrong
it's a treat you like Maid Marian as
well yes that is true she's a fox that
[Applause]
[Applause]
tunic is worn very low I know this he's
packin comedy and what happened was I
had always wanted to do stand-up comedy
I didn't have the guts to do it I got
very drunk I had a go at doing it as a
Bluecoat my mate said to me just copy
all the other comedians at Pontins and
steal their jokes and basically taught
to the front row so you're supposed to
say where you're from they say Scotland
you say who paid the holiday where you
from Wales you make a noise like a sheep
rubbish jokes but I said that's terrible
he said don't worry you're just padding
what you're doing is you're looking for
comedy gold
which is where you're from they say Kent
and you say what did you call me all
right now what Bolton is this used to
take the roof off right so I tried it
but I was very drunk so I go onstage and
I say where are you from bloke says
Scotland I can't remember the joke hello
were you from the guy says Wales I'd
black out and I go hi and then I say
anyone in from Kent shouts out me
and I said
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
people always end these things my story
provides the base of
hi what's your name my name is ileane
Aileen yeah I'm guessing with Marlon I'm
okay and you live there were here story
here I live over there
Oh what are you doing costume design
awesome interpretation okay there will
be subtitles on Friday no costume
interpretation if that costume design
isn't it fancy fancy it's fancier Frank
[Music]
okay off you go
right so lead-up to Christmas I was back
home and did you get any of it Chris I'm
thinking about Christmas yeah Christmas
that's the only good detail so far just
pick out words you'll follow the story
say blah blah blah Christmas blah blah
home to the shop and I had to get milk
and bread
[Applause]
so I was like rollin all right get the
groceries let's go told my boyfriend's
do lap and just pick me up nuni they
park the car so as planned
iq Moy you know perfect attainment
silver people carrier just casually
drift by casual speed so without
hesitation I sprint across when we look
we made groceries jump in the backyard
screaming and dump in the back of the
chair show them taking a mind games
Christmas and I had like a scarf up here
which was my boyfriend turned out to be
this middle-aged like six year old woman
push their fertile neck celery and a
selection of poor and sometimes frantic
just essentially lazy translations into
English on foreign menus okay so imagine
we're all in a restaurant together
yeah and I turned to Stan so what are
you going to get and Stan Lee might
reply well I'm going to get the sausage
and the father-in-law
[Laughter]
possibly
I don't know but the images that
conjures up it must be some sort of
toad-in-the-hole
it's getting worse this this is it I
mean really I don't think anybody
relative in it yeah and I don't think
anyone wants this German type sexual
harassment
[Laughter]
but I don't think you can go wrong with
a nice place of hand shredded ask me
everyone's favorite towards some more do
you know what wine pairing menu this is
a special brunch for the weekend I might
have the fresh salad followed by a
variety of opinions
but sometimes people are just a bit lazy
so this one there's bigger menu there's
some smoked cow feed and then they just
cow some something
just be finish but that person took a
bit of trouble this next person couldn't
be bothered at all
item number two on the menu whatever
tell me you did know you meet again we
move on to dessert now ladies gentlemen
oh oh let all of a bowl of nuts which
scum
you can get strawberries be discovered
we really want to push the boathouse why
not have some chocolate puke finally is
there anyone who live who doesn't like
sweet tight [ __ ]
translated it's true and this seems
unlikely that you own a single piece of
every bit of memorabilia that they
produced for Lord of the Rings
oh well that's half true so I've got a
few things from the actual film so I
have the ring I have sting I have a map
from Bilbo's study or the living room in
Bag End and I just recently because I
went back and did the final bit on The
Hobbit and they gave me the book that
Bilbo writes him he writes The Hobbit
there in makig in a Hobbit's tale and
then I finished it as little rings they
gave me that read volume which is actual
yeah whoa my last day in Hobbiton it was
pretty magical
I know amazing
[Music]
it's a real place no it's not right
[Applause]
his dream his feet a victim actually
built it they built it for Lord of the
Rings we took all of the the facades
away and then it since been a tourist
attraction and now it's been rebuilt for
The Hobbit but with sustainable
materials with real woods so it'll
always be there so from now on you'll
actually get to see Hobbiton and visit
it as a real place I'm able to stay
there Naoko but they are turning the
green dragon
[Applause]
yes we're going to Hobbiton for
Christmas I turned 19 when we first went
to Hobbiton and I'm 13 I was talking to
Pete when we were there on my last day I
said you realize that I had my 19th
birthday yeah
[Applause]
you know that it was going to take off
and be become a real place
good luck getting into New Zealand
bathroom
[Applause]
come on Graham good luck on you he's a
hobbit denier
[Music]
you